The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license, and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general, is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's resume.
I cut things off at a time when
we had the final answer.
And I left you hanging because
we don't know what the final
answer is telling us.
This says that as we change the
orientation of the normal
to the plate, relative to x3
and, secondarily, as we change
the angle between the threefold
axis and x2, we get
this strange third-rank
trigonometric function.
Let's convert these cosines into
the appropriate angles.
This was the twofold axis.
And this was x1.
This was the direction of
the threefold axis.
This was x3.
And this is the direction x2.
And that comes out in between
a pair of twofold axes.
And we may want to look at this
from up above, relative
to these twofold axes
that occur.
This thing here looks like
a trigonometric identity,
doesn't it?
Let's let this angle
here be theta.
And l1, then, is cosine
of theta.
And so our geometry is that this
is l1 cosine of theta.
This is l2, which is the cosine
of the angle between
our direction and x2.
And that is the cosine of
pi over 2, minus theta.
And that, then, is equal
to sine of theta.
So this identity, as
you all know--
I'm not telling you anything
that you don't already know--
this is d is equal to
d1,1 1, times the
cosine of 3 theta, right?
You knew that.
Believe it or not, it is.
It's one of these obscure
trigonometric identities,
which wouldn't occur to you in
a million years unless you go
digging through some
handbooks.
So this is rather astonishingly
simple.
It's simply a cosine function.
But the interesting thing
is it goes as a
function of 3 theta.
So this goes through one cycle
between a pair of adjacent
twofold axes.
So it starts out as d1,1.
And it finishes up at d1,1.
And in between it
is minus d1,1.
And so it goes down.
And now we come to something
that I do differently than
most people do.
Most people will say it
goes as minus d1,1.
But minus d1,1 I like to show
as a lobe going off in this
direction, with a minus sign.
AUDIENCE: How do you get
that cosine of 3 theta?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: How do you get d
equals d1 cosine 3 theta?
PROFESSOR: How do I get that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That is just a
trigonometric identify,
believe it or not, a well-known
trigonometric identify.
Actually, it's an exceedingly
obscure
trigonometric identity.
So the way this is going to go
from x1 is it's going to be a
positive lobe around x1.
There's going to be a negative
lobe along x2 and then a
positive lobe again about the
twofold axis that's 120
degrees away.
And then a negative lobe, and
then a positive lobe opposite
this negative lobe, and a
negative lobe opposite this
positive lobe.
So it's a six-membered--
six lobes.
There is always a positive lobe
opposite a negative lobe.
And what this means is that the
charge is of opposite sign
on opposite ends of
the twofold axes.
So the response peaks
up on twofold axes.
Now the thing that I don't like
is that what Nye does is
to say, OK, this is
a negative value.
So you should plot the radius
in a negative direction.
And that puts it over here,
right on top of
this positive lobe.
So what Nye shows is the polar
plot of this result, in the
plane of the twofold axes,
is simply this.
This is x1.
And he shows a lobe here.
And if you interpret that as a
polar plot you say, well, I
know what the value
is in here.
It's decreasing.
And there's nothing
going on in here.
So the response must be 0.
And then it starts
coming up again.
And there's a response in
different directions here.
And then it goes
back down to 0.
And in this range, there's
nothing going on.
And that's not true.
What's going on is a negative
value of the modulus.
And to me, that becomes
abundantly clear if you just
put a sign that labels the sign
of the modulus within
those lobes.
Now I submit, that's pretty
anisotropic, isn't it?
Yes, Steve?
AUDIENCE: Did you just
arbitrarily choose where your
positive and negatives
go, is it [INAUDIBLE]
out here?
PROFESSOR: No.
This comes out here.
When l1 is 0, that's--
excuse me.
When the angle is
0, l1 is plus 1.
Remember that l1 is the
cosine of this angle.
When that angle is 0, then
the value is plus 1.
So I was careful to put
the label x1 on this.
Now the other thing that we
should examine is how these
lobes vary in a direction
perpendicular to x, in a
direction that includes x3.
So let us look at how the
function varies in a direction
perpendicular to--
that includes x1 and x3.
OK.
Call this angle phi.
And in the x1, x3 plane, d1,1,1
prime turns out to be
l1 cubed d1,1.
Before you go to our
general expression.
And l2 is cosine of 90.
This thing drops out.
We're left with simply
d1,1 prime equals
l cubed times d1,1.
So this then goes as cosine
cubed of phi, which is a lobe
that starts out at plus 1.
And then because it's cosine
cubed, this dies out very,
very rapidly.
So these lobes are very flat in
the x1, x2 plane, die out
very rapidly as the cube of phi,
where phi is the angle
between the twofold
axis and x3.
So the interesting thing about
this surface is that if you
decided to pick up the random
fragment of crystal and
determine what its Piezoelectric
Modulus is.
One way of doing this,
a poor man's test for
piezoelectricity is to just
clamp a fragment of crystal
between two electrodes and
then hook this up to a
variable frequency generator
that sweeps through a range of
frequencies, changes the
frequency of a voltage across
these plates, and then comes
back and sweeps again.
Or alternatively, have
a knob one on that
lets you change frequency.
Then put a pair of earphones
across the crystal.
And if we would do that, by
having this variable frequency
generator, as we turned it,
when we hit a resonant
frequency that set up either
a full wavelength of a
vibrational wave in
the crystal--
or half wavelength, or one
wavelength, or 3/2
wavelength--
there'd be a resonance.
And the capacitance does
something crazy.
It does like this as
you go through
the resonant frequency.
And then your simple
detector--
a pair of earphones--
as you tuned the frequency, you
would hear static as you
went through this discontinuity
in capacitance.
Or alternatively, you could put
this on a cathode ray tube
and just have a sweep frequency
and put the voltage
across the electrodes on the
oscilloscope screen.
And you would see something
like this, and then this
discontinuity, and then
maybe second harmonic.
And it would work just fine.
This is a poor man's way of
detecting piezoelectricity.
But what if--
what if--
you happen to have your piece of
quartz with the electrodes
directly on the c-axis?
The modulus would be 0, and you
wouldn't detect anything.
Or if you put on the probes
such that they were in a
direction that was in between
these lobes where, again, the
Piezoelectric Modulus
has gone to 0.
You wouldn't find anything.
So measuring the Piezoelectric
Modulus for a random chunk of
material is dangerous, if you
just look at one direction and
say nothing's going on; it's
not piezoelectric.
The other thing is the
material could have a
piezoelectric response that's
so weak you just
can't measure it.
Yeah, OK?
AUDIENCE: This stuff's only for
single crystals, right?
Because if you [INAUDIBLE]
polycrystal material, you're
getting [INAUDIBLE] averaging.
PROFESSOR: You're averaging
over all directions.
So this is for a
single crystal.
And that's the only time you
get these exotic, very
anisotropic surfaces.
Another method that I've
seen in a rather old
book is really nice.
What you do is you cut your
crystal into a little plate.
And then you drive the plate by
means of putting electrodes
on it and hook this up to
a variable frequency.
And if the material is
transparent, you will set up--
depending on the velocity of
sound in the material--
you will set up standing
waves when you
hit the right frequency.
And these lines that I've drawn
are places where the
displacement is always 0.
And these things that I've
indicated at little squares is
a region where the displacement
goes up and down
between its maximum and
minimum extreme.
Now if this crystal is
transparent and you shine a
light through it, these little
regions bounded by lines of
zero displacement act
like little lenses.
So if you pass a beam of light
through it, you get a bunch of
right maxima, little focused
spots on the sheet.
And you can determine for a
particular frequency if this
is the 1 and 1/2 wavelengths
along a dimension that you
know, you can again find the
Piezoelectric Moduli.
So there are lots of ways of
detecting this effect.
But when you have a single
crystal, you've got to really
look at this as a function
of direction, to
be absolutely sure.
One other Piezoelectric Modulus
is in the problem set.
4 bar 3m, this is the structure
of sphalerite and a
lot of the compound
semiconductors.
This is not in the notes.
But if you try the problem,
what you find is, again, a
highly, highly anisotropic
behavior.
And this is the direction of the
unit cell of the crystal.
You find that the piezoelectric
response is a
series of very sharp lobes,
positive and negative, going
along the directions of the body
diagonal, namely the 1,
1, 1 directions in
the crystal.
And then there's another
lobe that goes like
this, negative, positive.
Another lobe that goes up here,
positive and negative.
So very sharp lobes along the
body diagonal, alternately
positive, negative, positive,
negative as you go around 0,
0, 1 plane.
OK.
That's what the longitudinal
piezoelectric effect is like.
You can invent single-crystal
devices for weighing fish.
And then you have an interesting
question.
If you hang the weight on the
crystal, and it's a flat
plate, how would you orient the
crystal to get the optimum
sensitivity?
So you define a scalar modulus
for the crystal in the
particular direction you're
exerting a uniaxial stress.
And then you express this module
in terms of theta, the
angle of rotation, within
the crystographic plane.
In the case of the sup cell if
you looked at that geometry,
that is a flat plate subject
to compression, where you
measure the surface charge
perpendicular to the direction
of the uniaxial stress,
not parallel to it
as we've done here.
And then there's a question if
you rotate the plane of the
crystal about the imposed
stress, what orientation gives
you optimum, maximum response?
So there are fun things that
you could do with that.
We have a quiz next time.
There's a lame-duck period after
the quiz will be over.
And I want to say a little bit
about the tensor aspects of
elastic moduli.
Mechanical behavior is something
that you have or
will cover in great detail in
a graduate-level class on
mechanics, but I think very
few people who deal with
things other than cubic
materials or with
single-crystal materials where
the elastic constants are
functions of crystal symmetry
and direction.
So let me, at least at the
time available, set up a
definition of stress
in terms of strain.
Stress is a second-rank
tensor.
There are six unique
components.
So we could write an expression
for sigma 1,1;
sigma 2,2; sigma 3,3; sigma
4,4; and sigma 5,5.
And sigma--
AUDIENCE: --1,2.
PROFESSOR: No, I want to
go down like this.
So this would be sigma 2,3;
sigma 1,3; and sigma 1,2;
eventually to be known as sigma
1, sigma 2, sigma 3,
sigma 4, sigma 5,
and sigma six.
But actually, if we're writing
out a full tensor relation, we
should write down all
six elements here.
So let me do that and
put in a 3,2.
Put in all nine of them, because
before we condense to
matrix form, that is what
we're going to have.
So we'll have a sigma 2,3; we'll
have a sigma 3,2; we'll
have a sigma 1,3; a sigma 3,1;
a sigma 1,2; and a sigma 2,1.
And we can express each of the
stresses in terms of the
elements of strain.
So I'll have an epsilon 1,1;
an epsilon 1,2; an epsilon
2,2; an epsilon 3,3; an epsilon
2,3; an epsilon 3,2;
an epsilon 1,3; an epsilon 3,1;
an epsilon 1,2; and an
epsilon 2,1.
Nine terms, nine terms.
And in between is going
to be a tensor
consisting of 9 by 9 elements.
There will be 81 different
coefficients in here.
If we want to derive symmetry
constraints, we're going to
have to, for every one of
those 81 elements, do a
transformation.
And each transformed element is
going to be a sum of four
direction cosines times one
tensor element, repeated 81
different times.
Not something to be undertaken
on a short afternoon.
OK.
What are the tensor
elements in here?
They are represented
by the symbol c.
This would be c1,1,1,1.
This would be c1,1,2,2 times
epsilon 2,2; a c1,1,3,3; a
c1,1,2,3; and so on.
And these c's, in one of the
great perversions of
scientific notation, are
called stiffnesses.
The other thing we could
do is to write
strain in terms of stress.
And really, stress
is something you
can do to the crystal.
So stress is an independent
variable.
And this is something that
I feel more at home with.
So I'll have an epsilon 1,1;
2,2; 3,3; epsilon 3,2; 2,3;
epsilon 1,3; epsilon
3,1; epsilon 2,1;
and an epsilon 1,2.
Again, nine elements
of strain.
And these will be given by
coefficients times each of the
nine elements of stress, sigma
1,1; sigma 2,2; sigma 3,3;
sigma 2,3; sigma 3,2; and
so on for nine different
components.
Andy the coefficients here are
designated with the symbol s.
These are the tensor elements.
So this is s1,1,1.
This is s1,1,2,2.
And the s's stand
for compliances.
Now English is a very
strange language.
But to call compliance s and to
call stiffness c is surely
a perversion that can be
designed for no other purpose
than to confuse the introductory
student and give
the instructor some feeling
of superiority.
I don't feel superior, I feel
embarrassed that I have to
explain this.
Stiffness, c; compliance, s.
It's got be one of
the atrocities
of scientific notation.
To remember which goes with
which, I'll tell you what
works for me.
If it doesn't work for
you, forget it.
The s goes with sigma.
And the little c goes
with the epsilon.
That's a c with a bar in it.
That works for me.
If it doesn't work for you, use
your own mnemonic device.
English does a lot of things
strangely, but nothing is as
perverse as this.
Now what's some examples?
Consider this.
You park your car in your
driveway, but you drive your
car on a parkway.
Why don't you drive your car
on a driveway and park your
car in a parkway?
No, it's the other way around.
It's almost as bad as this.
What are some other ones?
In my basement, I have something
that's called a hot
water heater.
You don't heat hot water,
you heat cold water.
Why isn't it called a
cold water heater?
Even better, I once worked
for a year and a half in
Switzerland.
And in the kitchen of my home
I had, in German, an
elektrowarmwasse
rsheissungsapparat.
That's one word that's
11 syllables.
The Germans have a knack with
the language that we have
never approached in English.
But there's another one
you've probably heard.
You know what the prefix
"pro" means.
That means for, and "con"
means against.
And so progress is moving
forward, and I leave it to you
to decide what Congress means.
OK.
So I could go on and on.
I probably shouldn't, unless
you egg me on.
No, I won't.
But anyway, there are--
OK, I'll give another one.
Why is what a doctor does
called "practice"?
This is not reassuring at all.
Let me invite you over
to my practice.
And why is it when you take an
airplane your flight ends with
a terminal?
That's doesn't sound very
encouraging either.
So anyway, language is silly.
And I guess if you want to
call c stiffnesses and s
compliances, it's OK.
The verbal description of these
terms means something.
Because if the stiffness is very
high, that says that a
little bit of strain requires
that you haven't posed a very
large stress.
So stiff is when the material
is resistant to stress.
So you have to have a very,
very large strain to get
yourself a given level
of stress.
Conversely, if the material is
very compliant, a very small
stress for a compliant
material should
give you a big strain.
And that's exactly what a large
value of s will do.
It will give you a large
strain for a
relatively small stress.
So the words describe
what's going on.
OK.
There is great utility in
reducing these equations to a
matrix form, which is going to
cut us down from a 9 by 9, or
a tensor with 81 elements, to a
smaller number of subscripts
and a smaller number of matrix
elements, so if we let sigma 1
be sigma 1,1; if we let sigma
2 be equal to sigma 2,2 and
sigma 3 be equal to sigma 3.
And then if we write the
inequalities we've had before,
and we let epsilon 1,1 to be
replaced by epsilon 1, then we
would have out in front here a
term simply c1,1, a 1 for the
sigma and a 1 for the epsilon.
The next term would be c1,2
times epsilon 2, where
obviously epsilon 2 has replaced
epsilon 2,2, and 1
stands for the two
indices, 1,1.
So this will go c1,3;
epsilon 3.
And then you hit these
messy factors of two.
You'll have a pair of terms.
You'll have c1,4.
And that will stand for
a term c1,1,2,3.
And then there'll be another
term c1,1,3,2.
And if you want to write this
as a matrix, c1,4 has to be
equal to the sum of these two
things, times epsilon 4.
That's the only way you can
write it as a matrix.
And if you think it was bad
worrying about a factor of 2
in front of half of the terms on
the right-hand side of the
equation, we're going to be
dealing with factors of 2 for
terms in the upper
3 by 3 array.
We're going to be worrying about
a factor of 4, somehow
or other, down in the
lower 3 by 3 array.
So the way you handle the
factor of 2 really is a
nightmare for relations
in elasticity.
But continuing on with the first
line, c1,5 times epsilon
5 would be a combination of
c1,1,3,1 plus 1,1,1,3.
And then finally, when you get
to c1,6 times epsilon 6, that
would represent a combination
of c1,1,2,1 plus c1,1,1,2.
You have to make a decision
where to swallow the 2.
And probably the best thing
I can do is to give you
conventions for relabeling
stress, strain, stiffness, and
compliance, which I'll
pass around to you.
No big deal, except that this
is a case where you can eat
the 2's early on, but you
can't even break even.
So very, very briefly, what
you do is you convert the
tensor elements of stress to
matrix elements in exactly the
same way we did with
piezoelectricity.
For strains, we do exactly the
same thing that we did with
the converse piezoelectric
effect.
The factor of 2 that you
swallowed in definition of
stress pops up to haunt
you when you
deal with the strains.
And you cannot write a nice
matrix relation unless you
divide the off-diagonal elements
of strain by 1/2.
And that was exactly the same
thing we encountered with the
converse piezoelectric effect,
which related strain to an
applied electric field.
In defining the matrix
stiffnesses, the c's, you
forge straight ahead, and you
let ci,j,k,l, which is
identical to ci,j,l,k--
that's the term that relates the
two equal shear stresses--
and you define that as a
matrix term with two
subscripts.
No factors of 2 or
4 are involved.
Then when you hit the s's,
there's a nightmare.
si,j,k,l is sm,n if m and n
are 1, 2, or 3; that is to
say, not 4, 5, or 6.
si,j,k,l, which is the same as
s,i,j,l,k, has to be defined
as one half of sm,n, where
m or n is 4, 5, or 6.
And then finally, you have to
throw in a factor of 4 when
both m and n are 4, 5, or six
or, in other words, m and n
are not 1, 2, or 3.
So it is a mess.
And these are rules that you
have to bear in mind if you're
ever going to go from matrix
form, which works absolutely
lovely in a fixed coordinate
system.
But if you have a single crystal
and you want to refer
it to different axes, you have
to be prepared to resurrect
the full tensor form.
And then and only then can you
work symmetry transformations.
I don't want to go through the
simple algebra of expanding
and contracting these terms.
So the next two sheets show
you how you condense from
tensor to matrix notation, and
then go back from matrix
notation to tensor notation.
This is for the compliances
si,j,k.
And the next page does the same
thing, if you care to
write stress in terms
of strain.
And there are a lot
more factors of
2 that appear there.
But again, it shows you how you
go from tensor notation,
for subscripts on the c's, down
to matrix notation with 2
subscripts, and then go back up
again to tensor notation.
So it's a tedious business.
And you've got to keep careful
tracks of your factors of 2
and your factors of 4.
How about symmetry
restrictions?
Holy mackerel.
Transformation of 81
different elements.
Well, in order to do the tensor
transformations, you
have to go to the full-force
subscript notation.
Only then is a law of
transformation defined.
Fourth-rank properties
are even tensors.
So mercifully, there are
not as many different
possibilities.
All point groups that differ
by presence or absence of
inversion have exactly the
same form of the tensor.
So symmetry 2, m, and
2/m look alike.
Symmetry 2, 2mm, and 2/m,
2/m, 2/m look alike.
So there's only one orthorhombic
tensor, only one
kind of monoclinic tensor, only
one kind of triclinic
tensor, and so on.
And the only place that you have
more than one form of the
tensor for a particular set of
point groups is looking at the
point groups that are based
on single-rotation axes,
something like 4, 4 bar 4m, and
those that are based on
the axial arrangements
4, 2, 2.
So they're different, just as
they were for second-rank
tensor properties.
For cubic, a rather
remarkable result.
There are three independent
compliances.
But cubic crystals are not
elastically isotropic.
They are anisotropic.
And it's just the nature of the
tensor that requires that.
So rather than letting you hang
by your thumbs wondering
what's on these pages, let me
pass around the summary of
symmetry constraints.
If you understood what we did
for third-rank tensors or even
second-rank tensors,
you how to do this.
And fortunately, the
terms almost over.
So I can't make you do it, which
is probably an enormous
relief to you.
Some additional bits
of information.
The transformations for
hexagonal crystals are
complicated because threefold
and sixfold axes do not change
the reference axes x1, x2,
x3 into one another.
And the equations that relate
the individual tensor elements
are more complex.
For the threefold axis, for
example, 2 s1,1 minus 2 s1,2
is equal to s4,4.
So they're not simple relations
between them.
And that's simply because
you're not changing one
reference access into another.
You're changing x1, for
example, into a linear
combination of x1 and x2.
Two things down here
of interest.
I said that cubic crystals
are not isotropic.
What would have to be
the case if the
material were to be isotropic?
Well, it turns out that if you
do this for the compliances,
s, if 1/2 of s4,4 is equal to
s1,1 minus s1,2, then the
material is elastically
isotropic.
If you do this in terms
stiffnesses, the c's, then 2
c4,4 is equal to c1,1 minus
c1,2 if the material is
supposed to be isotropic or
going to be isotropic.
Then there is one
other inequality
that depends on structure.
And this is something known
as the Cauchy relation.
And it depends on the
interatomic forces.
The first condition that has to
be met is that the forces
between the atoms should
be central forces.
What is a central force?
Well, this is a case where the
attractive force between the
atoms is directly along the line
joining their centers.
Isn't that always the case?
Don't crystals hold together
because there's an attractive
force between atoms?
Well actually, for metallic
crystals and ionic crystals,
maybe that's not a bad
assumption, particularly for
ionic crystals.
But if you had a covalent
material, where the bonding
was due to overlap of orbitals
like this, then the thing that
holds the crystal together
is overlap
between these orbitals.
And the force holding the atoms
together is a force that
goes through this shared
electron pair.
And that's not a
central force.
And so the Cauchy relation
generally fails rather badly
for covalently bonded
materials.
Second assumption is
that each atom is
at a center of symmetry.
And the reason for that is so
the force in the plus-x
direction is the same
as the force
in the minus-x direction.
And that is not true for any
material that has tetrahedral
coordination.
So it's not true for any
of the forms of SiO2.
It's not true for any of the
compound semiconductors that
are based on tetrahedral
units.
So there, the atom inside of
these tetrahedra is decidedly
not at an inversion center.
And finally, you assume that the
crystal is under no state
of initial stress.
Because if it is under initial
stress, you've squished it,
you've stretched the bonds.
And the forces--
not to a major degree, to be
sure, but-- the forces will
not truly be perfect
central forces.
So if all three of these
assumptions are satisfied,
then you have an additional
equality
c1,2 is equal to c4,4.
What I'll do next time is I'll
bring in some examples of data
for stiffnesses and compliances
and, in
particular, show you how some
of these elastic tensor
elements change with
temperature.
And we can examine them to see
how well the Cauchy equality
or the isotropy condition
is satisfied.
All right.
That's about all that we'll
do about the definition of
fourth-rank tensor properties.
On next Tuesday to wrap the
term up, we'll look at the
variation of some elastic
moduli, such as Young's
Modulus or the shear modulus,
for different symmetries as a
function of direction
in the crystal, OK?